we are indeed with Nazi paikiza after a
tremendous Victory Nazi congratulations
first of all this was a very tense match
but it felt like you were putting on the
pressure from the get-go even yesterday
with the black pieces it felt like you
had a dominant position did you feel
like that as well uh yes it I did feel
like that and Anna is a very tough
opponent for me I have never
this is my first time
uh turns out yesterday I missed a chance
there was a tactic that I missed in time
travel
uh so today I was really hoping to get a
position where I could fight for a win
and not get very dry Catalan draw
position so I was quite happy with the
line she chose when she took on F4 uh
all the way yes after that we get messy
Pawn structure and I was even
considering to Castle long although I
think that did you know this variation
up to this point or I glanced that at
this point I prepped so much but I
didn't expect this exact line and I just
very quickly looked at it so I just had
an idea that it's pretty okay for white
and I can attack on the king side so I
was happy with that and she was spending
also a lot of time and it felt like this
was a trademark of this matchup Anna was
spending a lot of time you were playing
very quickly did you prepare
specifically for this type of situations
uh I mean I've known Anna for a long
time and she's always in time trouble
when we were teammates at the Olympia
she was sitting next to me and after I
moved 10 she would have 10 minutes and
it would make me nervous so I was
expecting that and uh today honestly I
was
planning on that that if she gets in
time trouble and I have a chance to
attack I will definitely go for it and
it did feel like your attack just simply
was coming naturally yes position and
you played this move that really
impressed us
Rook to G1 yes yes how did you come to
this conclusion oh I love that move I I
didn't expect F6 and when she played it
um
I immediately saw Rook G1 and if she
takes on E5 I can take on E5 with either
pawns but I was contacted with d Bishop
before checking F1 and I'm getting that
Bishop back with A3
E3 and B4 uh there's also Knight F6
thread and if she tries to defend it
let's say B5 to make space right yeah
and uh yeah this just felt natural
I didn't really calculate I was playing
more instinctively at this point
and of course she uh played this move C5
which allowed you to go Knight to C4 the
key moment was here actually before D
takes C5 I paused because I noticed I
had D5 and it looked very interesting
because I'm threatening D6 if she takes
Queen D5 I win
and
but then I saw she can play bishop d8
and as ridiculously passive as that is I
couldn't find anything else after that
and you probably have to play it slow at
this point something yeah Knight D6 take
advantage of a lot better but
there's nothing immediate and uh just
frustrating you wanted the material yeah
you want to take on C5 yes sir probably
recommends that as well
just to interrupt you for one second
Alice Lee did indeed finish this match
with two zip impressive score
Let's uh continue
Knight to C6 and you are feeling like
you're taking over at this point right
yes plus she didn't have any time so
that helped a lot
yeah I like that I brought the queen
over because Queen did his job on H5 and
I had to bring it back to the queen size
getting closer to these pieces on this
side putting some pressure on E6 very
nicely done my only problem in this game
was that at times I had too many good
options yeah and couldn't decide which
move to make
and Irina has won her game as well and
she finishes it with two zip
wow very competitive matchups all the
games were decisive playoffs no playoffs
yeah no playoffs in the women's section
uh did you have any problems at any
point did you feel like you're sleeping
at any point or it just felt smooth no I
thought I was winning pretty much after
winning the pawn
on the clock but I still had the time
Advantage so
I didn't let her Escape
as a congratulations a huge victory for
you against anastasi guys any questions
our congratulations if you're gonna win
a game
winning uh when it was a decisive moment
that's a good time
to finally get a victory our
congratulations and I know exactly what
you meant when you said as an Olympic
teammate you were sitting next to her
and you're getting nervous I was the
team captain
I'm nervous for the whole round you know
but uh our congratulations good luck uh
in the next round yes well done